[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
gad non ça me rappelle une hausse et un
gars qui croisent son pote dans la rue y
croise son pote et son pote et en sang
il est griffé de partout lui manque une
non il les fera qu'à sa chemise et le
déchirer qui m'effraie rocky ce qui
t'arrive c'est quoi qu'est ce qui se
passe n'est plus temps on combien
enterrer ma belle mère l'a dit mais
pourquoi si dans cet état
elle voulait pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est une femme qui achètent une
amérique et à la montagne quatre heures
compliquées tout à droite les simples m
et 4 heures à monte l'armoire et tout
quand tout est fini il ya le bus qui
passent devant chez elle puis c'est une
route rend pas mais ça tremble un peu
et tout l'armoire s'écroule face au non
c'est pas possible elle recommence tout
ce coup ci avait que trois heures que
trois heures elle met toi tout est bien
fait pour elle et où elle a terminé le
bus passe ça tremble sur les pavés
l'armoire s'écroule là elle appelle les
kakis écoutez je suis avocate
j'ai bien fait le truc est tout
maintenant si vous m'en voyez pas
quelqu'un dans l'heure qui suit je veux
traîne en justice et votre marque vous
allez voir la pub que je vais lui faire
ils flippent tellement chez ikea il
envoie un mec
et oui je connais le modèle qu'est ce
qui s'est passé de 2 fois et s'est
écroulé aux questions de youtube le mail
qui monte l'armoire les emails une heure
c'est son boulot et montrent la revoir
et 1,2 ce qui passe par moi si tu roules
fait c'est bizarre quand même parce que
moi j'ai fait connais mon métier il n'y
a pas de raison je leur fais il refait
en trois quarts d'heure et bat son
record et moi de la revoir le bus passe
l'armoire s'écroule il est alors
peut-être ça viendrait peut-être de
l'intérieur alors si je me mettais à
l'intérieur qui est davis intérieur
extérieur
si je me mettais à l'intérieur je vais
peut-être un défaut de fabrication davis
ça me permettrait de localiser le
problème je mette à l'intérieur fermez
fermez le truc qu'on va attendre que un
but soit on va bien voir le maximum et
dans l'armoire et là il ya le mari de la
femme qui rentre et shalit à sénart voir
c'est génial tiens je vais les traîner
je vais mettre mon gazon il ouvre
l'armoire et là y voit un mec accroupi
dans l'armoire regarde le mec le mec
fait bon jour où vous n'allez pas me
croire mais j'attends le bus
[Musique]
c'est un type qui est qui se balade dans
la rue à bruxelles et qui y voit un type
promener deux chiens dont il la cause si
l'excusé moi monsieur de vous déranger
là deux marques à l'antenne la cosc et
lourdeurs et lui dit vous avez deux
chiens absolument magnifique du oui
c'est vrai dit ses deux chiens là sont
supers alors il dit oui mais parce que
il dit c'est toujours et msyah ses
séquelles race un édit voulez vous cher
monsieur celui ci est un labrador ou
telle autre
oui l'autre aussi oui et il dit c'est ça
coûte cher à l'achat parce que ma femme
a toujours rêvé d'avoir de la voiture et
due forme on parlait pas dit celui ci
m'a coûté une petite fortune fait notre
oui l'autre aussi ça mange beaucoup dur
alors ça ça d or celui ci me dévore
dévore dédié l'autre oui l'autre au
civil qu'un des six mois pourquoi chaque
fois que je vous pose une question vide
celui là est l'autre aussi a dit excusez
moi cher monsieur c'est très simple
parce que ce chien là est témoin et d'y
et l'autre fait oui l'autre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est un mari qui ne supporte plus le
chat de sa femme et donc ils décident
d'aller l'abandonner d'eau qui prend sa
voiture il prend le chat il abandonne à
20 kilomètres de chez lui il rentre chez
lui dès qu'il arrive chez lui il
retrouve le chat sur le pas de la porte
saint priest et se trouvait question de
l'abandonner avril il énervé reprend le
chat et remonte dans la voiture et là il
abandonne à 40 kilomètres de chez lui il
rentre chez lui et retrouve le chat sur
le pas de la porte
là il s'énerve il prend le shell 2 mai
dans la voiture et conduit fait 10 km au
nord 20 km au sud
15 km à gauche 40 km à droite il
abandonne le chat il part et avant
d'arriver chez lui il appelle sa famille
dit dis moi chérie le chat est à la
maison elle dit bah oui oui il vient
d'arriver il va passer au scanner parce
que je me suis perdu louis goudergues et
qu'ils voulaient c'est l'auto dérision
là c'est patrick bruel
ouais toi et bouder il meurt en même
temps ouais
j'arrive là au bon arrivants l'enfer de
la fédé gros forcément parce qu elle
arrive à la première tranche la première
porte à sion il ya une meuf et clan t il
la regarde
hélas elle entend une voix patrick bruel
pour les délits vous avez commis sur
terre
vous allez rester avec cette femme toute
votre vie les carrick et la meuf et les
claques et alain bras dans le dos à une
oreille
il remportait ce faire deuxième
tentative de voir n'importe qui apporte
un souffle une femme mais encore plus à
l'aise nous ici têtes éclatées cyril
hanouna pour toutes les bêtises que vous
avez pris dans votre vie vous allez
passer l'éternité avec cette femme
tu rentres à porter cela moi j'arrive la
porte à sion c'est qu'il kardashian
voilà comment où et la voile dit qu une
carnation
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]